we start with this the massive overnight
fire in the southwest valley
viewers like you sent us videos of the
apartment complex under construction
burning to the ground luckily nobody was
injured
this happened just before midnight near
tropicana and fort apache we have team
coverage of the fire and the aftermath
hector mejia spoke with witnesses to the
inferno but we start with bianca holman
with details from clark county fire
bianca this complex is a complete
total loss just take a look you can see
206 units for future families
gone on the eli at fort apache website
it mentions leasing starting next month
but
a value of almost 30 million dollars it
looks like this project is going to have
to be torn down
and rebuilt now our cameras captured the
fire
and the flames just appeared to be
shooting hundreds of feet into the air
a hundred firefighters responded to this
blaze clark county
las vegas north las vegas and henderson
fire departments there are also two
major factors that made this fire
difficult
one is in the construction phase so we
had exposed wood
exposed combustibles two is the
the wind the wind fueled the fire and it
pushed the fire
so it intensified the heat and also
pushed it to the south
now those wind gusts were around 30
miles an hour overnight
the apartment complex to the west of the
one that caught on fire
also received some damage and that was
from the heat now that it's daylight
investigators on the scene just trying
to figure out and pinpoint
what was the cause of this fire
reporting live from near fort apache and
tropicana bianca holman
8 news now